mortars
grenades
an automatic weapon fire
the soundtrack to a city bakmut still
under siege this footage released by
Ukraine's small remaining group of
Fighters now largely encircled by
Russian forces
an arrow so South Ukraine's president
vladimizelenski meeting and greeting
exhausted men with military medals and
heavy expectations
it is a pleasure for me to see you shake
your strong hands and know that you hold
the future of Ukraine in your hands
his office also releasing this video
from a hospital Ward one of hundreds in
Ukraine the injured here among the tens
of thousands wounded in a war that's
grinding on into its 16th month
meanwhile in russian-released footage
President Vladimir Putin greets
subordinates flanked by security
no sign of either his defense minister
or top General on this rare trip to
russian-occupied territory security
concerns kept them at home the Kremlin
says to avoid tempting the enemy a
command center his makeshift meeting
room mats blurred and walls camouflaged
he tells senior officers he wants their
feedback more than a year into a
conflict where Russian forces have
publicly scaled down several strategic
goals
it is important for me to listen to you
to hear your views to compare notes I
would like to begin your report about
the situation in Carson area then the
parisia area
see you later in the Hassan region reads
the sign
Ukraine hopes are counter-offensive in
the coming weeks May precipitate a more
permanent departure
Villa Marx Al Jazeera